now also remember as Democrats fuel even
more baseless tinfoil hat conspiracy
theories this time a cover-up by the
Attorney General bar look at this law
it's the obstruction law 18 USC 1505
look at the language
it requires intent any obstruction case
hinges on whether someone was corruptly
trying to influence the investigation I
think that's like if you have subpoenaed
emails the intent to delete them clean
out your hard drive with bleach pit bust
up your devices with hammers and take
out SIM cards that might show intent
only it's now to explain all this is the
attorney for the president former mayor
New York City Rudy Giuliani mr. mayor a
nine month FBI they concluded no there
there
we had a house Intel committee no
collusion bipartisan Senate committee no
collusion Attorney General bar quoted
robert muller no collusion now they've
moved on to this let's talk about the
law that i just mentioned
well it's actually disgraceful Sean I
mean the reality the reality is that to
obstruct justice you have to threaten
you have to impede you have to get in
the way of somebody let's let's go back
to the one that Weinstein and all of his
angry Democrats used to push which is
when the president allegedly said
president said this conversation that
never took place
he said to Flynn you know I hope you you
can see fit to drop this or not pursue
this first of all you don't have
obstruction by hope you have instruction
by coercion threat I'll break your legs
I'll take your food away or I'll I'll
kidnap your children i prosecuted a lot
of obstruction cases nobody ever started
an obstruction sentence with I hope and
nobody ever did obstruction by putting
out a legal memo for the whole world to
see and we're going to find out in a
week or two
how accurate bill bars summary was and
I'm going to tell you it's going to be
100% accurate bill bar is a great lawyer
and he is an extraordinarily honorable
man I
can't say that for the congressman who
were making all these wild crazy insane
threats their claim of obstruction
against the Attorney General the United
States is no better and the two year
claim of obstruction by the angry
Democrats that tried to claim the
president was obstructing President
obstruct anything and the best evidence
of that is they completed their darn
investigation how the heck did it get
obstructed nothing was obstructed and
and by the way it was very clear in the
Attorney General's letter that both he
and rod Rosenstein who appointed the
special counsel decided very quickly
without any consideration of the Justice
Department rule about whether or whether
or not you can indict a sitting
president but more importantly it was
being discussed the whole time and
there's also beyond intent there's no
crime so the president saying I hope
Flynn doesn't go to jail after serving
his country or fire and call me which he
had a right to do or saying it's a witch
hunt is not this would be nobody nobody
was obstructed this would be the
obstruction case to end all obstruction
cases in other words somebody obstructed
to obstruct an investigation of an on
crime that he didn't commit that he was
innocent of and then it turned out he
didn't obstruct that they interviewed
500 witnesses got 1.4 million documents
got every wish fulfilled and engaged in
some practices that are truly horrendous
like raids in the middle of the night
bringing CNN into to photograph raiding
Stone's house for example leaking now I
mean everybody misses the real point in
the real wrongdoing are the prosecutors
who just leaked
I thought Muller didn't leak ah yeah you
believe that one and I'll sell you the
Brooklyn Bridge let me change topics for
a second
in a few days there's an election in
Israel both of us have been friends with
Prime Minister Netanyahu for a long time
you now have this crazy opponent many
Ganz's his name who actually is pushing
he's saying to the people of Israel Oh
Putin is trying to help Bibi Trump is
trying to help Bibi and without any
evidence whatsoever and I'm thinking if
there's one guy that has had moral
clarity and been a Churchillian figure
understanding the moral and
of our time its Prime Minister Netanyahu
on Golan on Jerusalem etc well maybe
there's a consistency here what the
president did was to help Israel you
know twice with the embassy and then
with go on and many other things
president had a reverse the betrayal of
Israel by Obama and right so I mean the
president has been a great president for
Israel but that also he comes after
Obama who was the worst president for
Israel it's the best relationship Eve
Israel it just so happens that in
helping Israel he helps the Prime
Minister but but what do you suppose not
help Israel it was this has been the
best relationship between Kath Jerusalem
now being the cap recognized capital
Golan Heights for protection I hope the
people of Israel understand I hope they
understand however Ben they've also
developed a real good alliance with the
Arab countries around them yeah so that
they they pose now a real substantial
defense to Iran all right Thank You mr.
mayor